i i make mistakes and i don't always do
as well as i would want to there are
days that i go home and realize that
i may have left a mark on someone and
there are days that i have to
either pick up the phone or send a text
and apologize to someone for for doing
it wrong
so it's not i don't want to lead you or
your listeners to believe that i get it
right all the time
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthrate excel j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
today we're going to be talking about
leadership from a very very interesting
simple but meaningful standpoint meet
philip kane
philip is a husband father and
businessman he has led a successful
career in some of the world's best known
corporations working for brands like
goodyear pirelli and napa
kane has had the privilege to lead
thousands of individuals and has managed
billions of dollars in value for
stakeholders crediting his father a
polish sales manager and a nigerian
priest with almost every good thing he
has learned about life leadership
business and the art of storytelling
kane proved for 30 years that the need
to choose between winning and caring for
others is a myth
kane lives in ohio with his wife three
children and four wonder dogs the not so
subtle art of caring is his first book
philip kane welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm fantastic thank you for
having me i'm glad to be here
well i'm glad that you're you're
giving me some of your attention today
because we're going to be talking about
a really really important
concept which is you know not just
leadership but you know different ways
of exerting a powerful leadership and
powerful in the sense of good leadership
where people want to follow and want to
want to
run forward through caring
and and i'm excited to talk a little bit
about your book on letters on on
leadership and
hearing and so it's going to be a fun
conversation and philip i want to get
started by understanding sort of your
why and why
did you decide to spend so much time
thinking about
caring and leadership and how these two
things come together
right
so let me go back all the way to the
beginning and before you or any
listeners roll your eyes and say oh my
gosh this is only a 20 minute
conversation i'll promise to do it fast
so
i grew up in the truck business my
grandfather was a truck dealer my dad
was a truck dealer and my dad was a
servant leader before there was even a
word for it so i grew up
learning to leave this way
and so
when
when i finished school and came back to
work for my dad and my dad said hey
i've got a rule same rule as my dad had
you can come to work here but you got to
go work someplace else first
and i went out into the world i took
with me a style of leadership
that
taught me
that you deliver results by being kind
to people and by being
careful toward people
and so when i ran into a style of
leadership that was more micromanaging
more archetypal
around
drilling people
for me that was foreign i had never seen
that before because what i had seen was
a style of leadership that held people
accountable but treated them like human
beings
and so for me
the the next 30 years of my career felt
like swimming against the stream not
with it and so
writing my book was
was kind of the natural conclusion to a
career spent
encountering a style of leadership that
i didn't particularly care for and
wanting to share with the world news
that hey there's a better way to treat
people than
what you've encountered probably
throughout your career
i think that everybody in the world
would can potentially agree on this
notion that we want to be kind leaders
we want to be kind individuals we want
we don't want to hurt others we don't
want to put down others yet we do as a
society it's why is that why is it that
you found throughout your life that the
form of leadership you're you're
discovering is not the form that you
grew up with as an inspiration
i think that we're
we're
we're just brought up to believe that
the most expedient route
is
is to hammer people right
we're just we're taught that
punishment is the the quickest route to
to achieving goals
right and so it carries forward into the
workplace that if someone doesn't
deliver
you punish them
if someone doesn't do what they're told
you punish them and so that's the style
of leadership that's most prevalent in
in the western world
and and so
we're also taught that if
if you treat people with kindness if if
you don't punish them when they don't
deliver you're viewed as a soft leader
right um
and and so and then you're shuffled out
of the deck because
at each promotional opportunity
uh the leaders look for
the the hard leader the the most
outgoing the most
gregarious the most likely to treat
people poorly and so leaders like me
tend to get shuffled out of the deck
because the the skills that they bring
to the party are soft or so they think
and and so i think to answer your
question that's why it happens because
we're taught that the the most expedient
way to deliver results is through
punishment not through encouragement
and you disagree with that
of course i do
and i have 30 years to prove that it
i'm ready to be convinced i'm
ready well think well think about i mean
think about your own
self um and and i could go through a
litany of things but if to just ask you
uh if if you had your choice between
being hit in the back of the head
or or being encouraged which would you
prefer
out of the two and of course you would
say i would prefer to be encouraged
right that is true for
for all of us
and so
for me and what i learned from my father
was that that it's it's not
it's not the extreme opposite of
punishment because there is a style of
leadership called servant leadership
that that just pretends hey just treat
everybody with extreme kindness and the
results will follow the trouble is they
don't
because there has to be a result in mind
there has to be a score kept there has
to be something that we're playing for
and so what what i ascribe for is to
hold people accountable but to do so in
a way that doesn't destroy their dignity
that that doesn't disrespect them that
doesn't treat them with anything other
than abject kindness
and so that that's what i hold up for
because if you think about the extreme
styles of leadership where you have
beating the heck out of people on one
end
and you have being extremely kind to
them on the other end
the results won't follow right because
if i'm beating you to death on one end
the minute i turn my back you'll stop
doing what i'm respect
the same as on the other end if i'm
being nothing but kind you all the time
you'll learn after a while that the you
know pushover
because there there's no consequence to
not delivering
so there there has to be a consequence
to non-non-delivery
but that can come in a way that doesn't
tear you apart as a human being so what
where have we seen
you know the this more positive
leadership happen in our in our daily
lives what have been some successful
examples of of this type of caring
leadership excerpt
well i i think it's it's difficult to
find because it's not the norm but i but
you can see it in places like
with like richard branson at virgin
atlantic um
musk for
um for the most part delivers this um
type of of leadership although um most
recently the the media
has liked to pounce on a few areas where
they think that he doesn't
lead like this but for the most part
elon musk um leads like this the late
tony say um
at zappos led this way
um so those are a few examples of people
that that lead with a
more encouraging and caring style of
leadership
so so paint me a picture of how this
tangibly plays out so as a leader you
know you're you're in a in a
confrontational situation something
doesn't happen the way that you expect
it to somebody under delivers for
example
what what is the tangible way of a pro
of approaching obviously one way is to
fire punish demote whatever it may be in
whatever setting
how does a
more caring leader
turn this around into an opportunity of
growth in in the way that you're you
know inspiring for it to be
so just think about a situation where
you went eight tenths of the way there
on something
the the more traditional
management
route would be to point out the
the last
two tenths of the way that you didn't go
and to punish you for not
achieving that
okay the the the leadership style that i
ascribed would be to to point out to you
that
that hey you did a really good job on on
the eight tenths of the way that you
went but it could have been even better
if
you went to the last two
and
and here's what what i need you to do
next time for this to be a complete job
and i want to make sure that you
understand how to go
all
10 steps of the way so
help me understand that you
understand how to go the whole way
and if there's anything that you need
from me to go
the whole way because next time i'm
gonna expect you to go the whole way
and if you can't we're gonna have a
different conversation next time
but again great job
on the first eight steps
not so good on the last two
next time i need you to go all 10.
right the conversation doesn't need to
be any different than that
you still know you let me down
you still feel bad about not going the
whole way you know that next time you
have to go the whole way
you've told me if there's anything
standing in your way of doing that
you've told me if there's anything i
need to take out of your way of doing
that
and it's been a conversation that didn't
destroy your dignity
isn't it
and we've accomplished the same thing as
me hitting you in the back of the head
right i mean it almost sounds like you
know
maybe partially a an underlying problem
that started here was sort of this
default expectation that as a leader i'm
starting out with this expectation that
this person will will prove will
sort of provide 10 out of 10 and if they
don't then
then that's sort of out of the norm but
maybe if i adjust the expectation to say
okay this is what this person is
performing now and my and what you're
basically saying is that the measurement
was now these incremental incremental
um
progresses that are that are climbing
obviously
but that initial default expectation
shouldn't necessarily be that perfect
mindset right
well what
everyone should still understand that
hey ten's the goal
but if they go all the way to 10 it
doesn't have to be a a career limiting
or career-ending
experience or conversation it doesn't
have to be a
a spirit-robbing conversation because
not one's going to go all the way every
time and so
um what needs to happen is a
conversation that says hey um what you
did was pretty good
but it could have been even better if
you went the whole way
so help me understand you need anything
for me to go the whole way next time
right now how do you i mean let's take
it one step further now i want them to
authentically be open about why they
didn't go the whole way maybe it's a
something that they disagree with maybe
it's
not they didn't want to they didn't care
for that or maybe that there's something
that is
that is inhibiting them from doing so
but how do i get them to now
communicate that with me because if they
don't actively communicate that then
they're not going to be able to succeed
the next time around either
right which is exactly the conversation
that i'm having with you right or i'm
trying to role model with you right now
by saying is there anything that you
need from me to be able to go
the whole way next time do you
completely understand
what you need to do to go the whole way
next time so that that's what i'm doing
as a leader is making sure that i've
done the things that i need to do
to enable you to do the whole job
do you completely understand what's
required of you to be able to do the
whole job right do you have everything
you need to do the whole job is anything
in your way that i need to remove
in order for you to be able to go the
whole way
so because that's what's missing
oftentimes in life
we we as leaders just assume that hey
just because i told you you need to go
all 10 steps that were indemnified from
any further culpability in the
relationship because i told you
i told you what she needs to do so i'm
out i'm done
now it's on you
no it's not i need to do
basically
five key things i need to tell you what
i expect from you
i need to make sure you understand how
to do that i need to make sure that you
understand why that's important
i'm and i and more than anything i need
to understand
that you know
that
when you accomplish that that your life
is going to get better as a result right
right
if i haven't done all of those things as
a leader
i'm not done
because just telling you what to do
isn't enough
you need you need to know
how to do those things you need to know
why it's important
you need to know
why it matters
not just to me but to you and the to you
part means
that you know that your life is going to
get better as a result of you getting it
done
because otherwise you don't
care right
so going back to sort of default
leadership styles or
maybe we take the conversation a little
bit more optimistic so you know aspiring
leaders new young leaders how do we
implement this in our day-to-day is this
simply constantly reminding ourselves
that you know let's think of this
this way this more caring way let's turn
around this conversation because it sort
of feels like we've been hardwired
through our own experiences from
childhood to
sort of
punish you know something that's gone
wrong instead of look seeing it as a
growth opportunity
i
i think and because i get asked this a
lot
how do you operationalize this yes as
as
because i think people come from a frame
of references that says um holy cow
sounds like a great idea but how in the
world would you operationalize this well
it's actually the easiest thing in the
world to operationalize because you just
approach it from the standpoint of
treating people the way that they want
to be treated and it's no more difficult
than that
so
wake up in the morning
and treat people the way that they want
to be treated
and recognize the fact that that other
there is
no one almost no one except for
psychopaths and psychopaths are a very
small percentage of the population but
no one wakes up in the morning thinking
you know what today's the day that i'm
going to go in and make my boss's life a
pure living hell
today is the day that i'm going to go in
and do the exact opposite of what's
expected of me
today's the day that i'm going to go and
be mediocre people don't do that
people wake up and truly believe
that they're good at what they do when
they add value
and so if they're not delivering whose
fault is it it's not theirs sure right
because they believe they're good at
what they do and they add value
so it's the fault of the leader
because they haven't made it clear what
they expect people to do why
it's important that they do what they do
and that when they do what they do their
life's gonna improve and so
operationalizing what we're talking
about here is no more complicated than
making certain that we as leaders are
treating people the way that they want
to be treated
sure and this is not just for top
leadership this is for a leader in any
capacity
and and it's sort of it's not just
bought you know top-down leadership it
could be horizontal leadership it could
be also bottom-up leadership that just
that
that way of communicating perhaps
frustration in any domain
towards a
you know just
very honestly communicating what was
good where did the action not meet the
expectation and what we would like to
see next time it doesn't have to
necessarily be sort of manager to
employee type conversation right
no exactly this
you said it even better than i could
this
this applies to all aspects of your life
and all 360 degrees
of your life and and for for you and for
your listeners
think of it this way
if you want to prove to yourself that
it's real
think in your life about those people
whether it was a teacher whether it was
a coach whether it was someone
in your community the people that have
had the most impact on your life or that
we're the most special in your life
and i promise you that those people are
going to be
the people that were the most
encouraging
of you in your life
not the people that beat the hell out of
you the most in your life
sure
that makes perfect sense
why why do you care so much about this
why is this something that is so deeply
motivating for you
and important for you
because i've seen the opposite of this
and i've seen what it does to people
and
because
it matters to me
that i leave the world a better place
than i found it
and so for me
that's what this is
all about it's a it's a mission of sorts
i realize that
it's not about me
and
and so i wake up every day wanting to
to leave people in this place better
than i found it so that's what was this
uh was this an ongoing journey
that you've
sort of have been able to to get to this
realization is this is this an overnight
type of realization
no it wasn't it
it
really wasn't any of those things i i
don't suppose it was just
that
and it wasn't that i had anything to
prove either it was that this was the
way that i was brought up to lead and
teach
other people
and
and for me it's it's my life has been
about trying to make it about other
people and i'll tell you that i
i i make mistakes and i don't always do
as well as i would want to there are
days that i go home and realize that
i may have left a mark on someone and
there are days that i have to
either pick up the phone or send a text
and apologize to someone for for doing
it wrong
so it's not i don't want to lead you or
your listeners to believe that i get it
right all the time
but but for me it's been
something that in my life i've tried to
do
because
i was raised by a man who taught me to
do it
better
and so that's what it's been for me is
just a lifelong journey of trying to do
it better
uh this was very impactful for me i
appreciate it i'm again i'm going to
take
uh this for myself very wholeheartedly
and i'm referring throughout this
conversation reflecting back to my own
relationships
my own communication styles and how
how i can come with this mindset and
and i really appreciate your work philip
i can feel the
the how genuine it is and how authentic
it is and and it's um
it's very heartwarming and i i very much
appreciate it so thank you thank you
very very much and i hope at least one
other person
enjoyed this as much as i did thank you
thank you thanks for having me i really
enjoyed it thank you